et on accueille tout de suite par
visio-conférence Manon lepomme bonsoir
bonsoir connecter depuis la Belgique
votre pays vous êtes humoriste et vous
serez prochainement sur une scène
yvelinoise puisque vous serez en
spectacle sur la scène de la Royale
Factory à Versailles du jeudi 16 février
au samedi à 18 février dans votre one
woman show je vais beaucoup mieux merci
on va peut-être voir toutes les
informations s'afficher dans un instant
et c'est donc un nouveau one man one
woman show après je n'irai pas chez le
psy où vous avez tout de même réussi le
tour de force Manon le pomme d'éviter à
250 000 spectateurs d'aller chez le psy
ça va ça va vraiment mieux aujourd'hui
Manon le pomme
et bien pour le savoir il faut venir
voir le spectacle c'est ça l'enjeu
évidemment bah oui le spectacle
s'appelle je vais beaucoup mieux merci
je crois que si vous venez voir le
spectacle vous allez très vite vous
rendre compte que je ne vais pas si bien
que ça c'est pas une suite beaucoup de
gens m'a demandé est-ce que c'est la
suite du précédent j'ai pas vu le
précédent pas du tout ce n'est pas du
tout une suite et c'est un spectacle ou
ben voilà j'ai 34 ans je fais un peu le
bilan est-ce que la petite Manon serait
fière de la grande Manon j'ai pas
d'enfant est-ce que j'en veux si j'en ai
comme est-ce que ça va se passer je
ressemble de plus en plus à mes parents
et ça c'est absolument terrible et donc
je cherche par tous les moyens de faire
le ressembler et ce qui est très
chouette avec ce spectacle c'est qu'il
est vraiment intergénérationnel il y a
plein de gens qui venaient avec leurs
ados par exemple sur les fait mourir de
rire eux en tant que parents ça les fait
rire les gens de mon âge bah ils se
retrouvent dans plein de questionnements
que je peux avoir sur le spectacle donc
du coup c'est un spectacle que je
conseille à tout le monde et puis alors
si vraiment vous avez pas d'idées voilà
Saint-Valentin moi je joue 16 17 18 donc
le 14 vous offrez maintenant le pomme et
puis on se rend compte le 16 le 17 ou 18
alors on va danser la bachata Véronique
dans les Yvelines et après on va voir
Manon le à Versailles le programme était
établi peut-être un petit passage aussi
par la street food japonaise pour faire
cette Saint-Valentin alors
malheureusement un extrait de votre one
woman show
regarde un peu les pays
elles sont en train de fleurir
allez comme ça et comment est-ce que
j'en suis arrivé à me réjouir de
regarder à faire conclure
moi mon idole quand j'étais petite c'est
qu'elle n'est plus et la fois là vous la
traversée ce champ de mine en 10
personnages vous souvenez de ça et moi
je regarde attends je
comme ça
vous l'avez dit vous ai raconté votre
vie de Néo trentenaire vous avez 33 ans
alors il y a des anecdotes qui sont
tirées directement de votre vos
expériences personnelles pourquoi ce
thème de la trentaine pourquoi l'aborder
dans ce spectacle
moi ça me rend besoin d'un an c'est un
spectacle et en janvier 2021 je me suis
dit mais pourquoi j'ai envie de parler
et en fait je me suis rendu compte que
j'avais plein de questionnements que je
me sentais très très vieille alors que
les gens me disaient ma femme Manon tu
es pas bien et tu as 30 ans j'avais 32
ans en fait à 32 ans et puis et puis du
coup de là est parti en fait ben c'est
vrai c'est un concert très marrant entre
deux ans de sentir très très vieille et
de là j'ai réfléchi à plein de choses on
a beaucoup discuté avec le co-auteur et
le metteur en scène et puis ben ça a
donné ça a donné ce spectacle et en fait
j'ai repensé à entre guillemets un peu
tout ma vie et qu'est-ce qu'elle dirait
la petite Manon comment elle me verrait
et puis de la découlait mais plein de
sketchs et plein de thèmes en rapport
avec ça alors 30 ans ça change
réellement la vie
mais oui mais c'est terrible mais vous
n'êtes pas encore concerné vous êtes
plus jeune moi je suis concerné
justement il y a les questions qui
reviennent les enfants le mariage etc on
les pose un peu plus quand on passe la
trentaine ah oui et on vous regarde
autrement aussi quand vous pose la
question ah vous avez pas encore
d'enfants on a un peu inquiet pour vous
les gens sont plus inquiets que vous et
donc ça c'est assez interfellant et
d'avouer votre passion pour Lady Di
c'était une épreuve pour vous de la voix
dans ce spectacle
mais pas du tout j'ai une certaine
fierté et d'ailleurs ça me vient de ma
mère parce que ma mère était assez fan
aussi et donc ça aussi j'ai eu envie
d'en parler parce que parce que je suis
vraiment fan parce que je connais plein
de choses sur elle et les gens de ma
génération vous disent enfin comment ça
se fait que tu connais autant de choses
sur cette personne mais je dis mais
parce qu'elle est fascinante et donc
voilà j'en parle brièvement dans le
spectacle c'est un spectacle hyper
personnel franchement les 95% et je fais
exprès de dire 95 pour qu'on sache bien
d'où je viens 95% des choses sont vraies
25% des choses sont des histoires que
j'ai vécues et donc c'est aussi je crois
que ça fonctionne c'est parce que c'est
un spectacle très personnel en fait très
sincère et donc on s'y reconnaît et vous
le fait d'ailleurs avec beaucoup
d'autodérision on peut dire que c'est un
peu votre marque de fabrique de parler
de ce de ces sujets justement avec des
régions
oui bah c'est ce que les gens disent
c'est toujours très difficile évidemment
de demander un artiste mais comment est
votre spectacle quel est votre type
d'humour donc moi je reprends toujours
ce que des gens ont dit de moins parce
que les gens disent c'est que c'est très
généreux c'est très spontané parce que
c'est vrai que même si un texte qui est
écrit moi je fais toujours des
improvisations à chaque spectacle ce qui
rend les représentations très uniques et
ben voilà là je vais aller jouer en
région en région parisienne tout près de
Paris à Versailles en plus donc c'est
pas n'importe quoi et donc en tant que
belge bah évidemment on va faire des
petites références et comme je dis
toujours ben c'est pas parce que c'est
pas parce qu'on est belle ce qu'il faut
se de nos gueules ça fait 35 ans
que les Français se foutent de notre
gueule donc maintenant on se venge et
donc je ris de beaucoup de choses mais
je ris avant tout de moi-même c'est
l'essentiel une petite question aussi
j'ai lu que vous vous rêviez petite
princesse j'ai lu ça quelque part et
vous avez été également enseignante il
me semble dans votre carré comment vous
êtes tombé dans l'humour finalement
qu'est-ce qui vous a fait atterrir dans
dans ce dans ce domaine là
alors sa princesse je ne savais pas vous
me la prenez
et donc oui j'ai été prof j'ai toujours
voulu être comédienne en fait depuis
toute petite et puis mes parents étaient
pas très très chaud et donc j'ai fait
des études supérieures qui étaient pas
des études artistiques et puis j'ai été
enseignante j'adorais je me suis
beaucoup amusée honnêtement j'ai adoré
enseigner et puis je commençais à jouer
de plus en plus être plus en plus sur
scène et donc à un moment donné j'ai
lâché et maintenant ça fait 8 ans que je
suis comédienne à temps plein
le thème de la trentaine trentenaire en
plateau est-ce que c'est période de dont
vous gardez des souvenirs est-ce que ça
a été une étape dans votre vie Véronique
les gens de 30 ans en général enfin ont
du mal à être drôle et ils sont un peu
vieux dans leur tête parce que justement
ils ont tout ça qui retombe dessus et on
les comprend mais il faut se rassurer ce
qu'après on doit revient très vite jeune
et drôle voilà enfin maintenant elle est
drôle mais ça veut dire c'est c'est vrai
non je peux être pesant quelque part
alors moi je suis en plein dedans donc
du coup je le redeviendrai au le bientôt
on a 10 ans pour pour être drôle donc
j'estime ça va bien pour moi voilà pour
les 30 ans que ça va plutôt bien on
parle qu'on a 30 ans on parle de la
crise de la quarantaine alors avoir
bientôt pour l'instant ça va nickel
voilà moi j'arrive vers 40 ans donc mais
je me souvenir d'avoir eu de crise de la
fontaine ou quoi enfin j'avais hâte en
fait de d'avancer en âge voilà ce qui a
changé réellement pour Manon le pomme il
faudra aller à la Royal Factory du 16 au
18 février donc ce spectacle accueillant
qui ont tourné c'est quoi les projets
pour 2023 c'est de continuer cette
tournée Manon le pomme oui bah le but
c'est de la tournée je vais un peu
partout en France je vais de plus en
plus en France donc ça c'est super je
retourne au Festival d'Avignon parce que
j'y étais en 2022 on y retourne en 2023
parce que ça a bien marché et donc on va
est-ce qu'on peut me souhaiter oui je
pense à ça une belle tournée avec plein
de dates et plein de publics donc du 16
au 18 février ce sera du côté de la
Royal Factory à Versailles info est
réservation vous avez vu le lien
s'afficher c'est directement sur le site
de la Royal FA